-I´ve been such a fan of yours
for so long.
And this year --
just a fantastic year.
"The Leftovers" ended,
which was such a wonderful show.
"Fargo" -- such a great season.
You´re Emmy-nominated
for "Fargo."
-Congratulations for that.
-Thank you. Thank you!
-And I have some questions
about those shows.
But I´m always fascinated
by what people did
in their early life,
before they were actors.
You worked at a Best Buy.
-I did.
-In -- Near Cleveland.
-Near Akron, yes.
-Near Akron. Of course.
And that makes even more sense
because a young LeBron James
would come to the Best Buy.
-Yes, he did.
He would come all the time.
He was so tall.
-Yeah.
-And he would come
to my brother´s theater.
He worked at a Regal Cinema.
And it was very personal
for us, always,
this LeBron James business,
Because my brother
told my mother
that if LeBron left Cleveland
that he wasn´t going to propose
to his girlfriend.
-Oh, no.
-And so I was watching --
My parents were visiting me
in grad school or something,
and we were watching
"The Decision" on TV.
And as soon as he said it,
my mom burst into tears.
-Oh, no.
-´Cause she was horrified.
Now, my brother was just,
you know, buying some time.
He didn´t really mean it.
She´s a fantastic woman.
They´re married.
They´re very happy.
-Okay, good.
-Has a happy ending.
-Well, it does, also,
´cause LeBron came back.
And that allowed
for their love to flourish.
-Yes, of course,
and we were happy to have him,
´cause we really needed a win
in Cleveland.
Let´s be clear about that.
-Good. I´m glad you got one.
Hopefully you´ll bring
an Emmy back to Cleveland.
-Oh, my gosh. I hope.
-Yeah, that would be great.
-I don´t think so.
[ Laughter ]
-You don´t think you´ll win or
you don´t think you´ll bring it
back to Cleveland if you do?
-Oh, back to Akron.
I keep calling it Cleveland.
-Touché. Touché.
They´re close enough.
-I want to ask about this,
because both
"The Leftovers" and "Fargo"
I would say had sort of --
There was a bit of vagueness
to the endings,
which is very much in line
with what those shows are.
But you have not --
In interviews, you have not
gone out of your way
to try to explain to audiences
what you think,
as an actress, happened.
Was that a choice you made?
-Absolutely.
Because, A,
who cares what I think?
And I say that because --
You know, what´s important is
not the experience that I have.
It´s the experience
that you have.
And I wouldn´t want to
rob anybody of that moment
of sitting with
what happens in those shows
and thinking about for
themselves what they believe.
Because what it does
is it reveals more about you
than it does about me.
I had an acting teacher
that used to say --
I would always be crying
in scenes, you know?
And he´d be like,
"Carrie, dry it up.
Like, it doesn´t matter
if you cry.
It matters if we cry."
And I think
that´s absolutely right.
-That´s great.
-So I´m just Captain Ambiguity.
I´ll do all your
ambiguous endings.
-And then, you know,
I have not been able
to stop thinking about the end
of "The Leftovers."
You obviously
played that character, Nora,
for a very long time --
three seasons.
Now that you´ve been gone
from it for a while,
do you still feel a connection
with that character?
-Oh, sure. I mean,
she taught me a lot about
how to walk into a room.
You know, she´s --
she´s much -- she´s much
less compromising than me.
I was such a people-pleaser
in my 20s, you know?
And I think she just
didn´t put up with any of that.
And it really changed the way
that I sort of stand and be.
That´s fantastic.
What a gift to get from a role.
-Oh, absolutely, yeah.
-That´s fantastic.
-That´s the best part of my job.
-Another good part
of one of your acting roles is,
you met your husband in a play.
-I did.
-Tracy Letts,
fantastic actor and writer.
-Yeah, he´s pretty great.
-And you met him --
Though, you met him
on a production of
"Who´s Afraid
of Virginia Woolf,"
which is not where you think,
like, marriage is great.
-No, it´s not usually --
It´s not usually
an endorsement of marriage.
-Yeah.
-But, in fact,
I think our production
was so successful because,
you know, Pam McKinnon,
our director,
and then Tracy and Amy, who
were playing George and Martha,
they approached it
as a love story.
And I remember talking about it.
They said,
"It´s a love story,"
and Tracy would always say,
"Wouldn´t you want your partner
to fight for you that hard?"
And that was such a beautiful
way of thinking about that play.
-Yeah.
That is definitely not --
I need to go back
and watch it again.
-Yeah, you should.
It still works.
It´s a very good play.
No, I´ve never been bored
ever watching it.
-Fantastic.
-And you and I
have something similar,
which I´ve told this story
on the show before.
When I got married,
the day of our wedding,
my wife had food poisoning,
and we actually
had to go to the emergency room
in the morning.
It all worked out.
But you had one --
You didn´t even
get out of the hospital.
-No, unfortunately.
You know, in Illinois,
when you get married,
you have 60 days,
and then --
-What do you mean
you have 60 days?
-Well, you have to register.
-Okay.
-And if you don´t get married
in 60 days,
you have to go
and pay and reregister,
and nobody wants to do that.
-Right.
-And it was day 59.
I was actually
doing "Gone Girl" in L.A.
-So why did you wait so long?
Why´d you let it get to day 59?
-We´re actors.
We hardly see each other.
-Okay, gotcha.
-I´ve been married four years.
It feels like 1 1/2.
-Okay, great.
-So, I came home the night
before it was gonna expire,
and I said,
"We have to go tomorrow."
And he said, "Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I´m not feeling very well."
We go to the emergency room,
he has emergency gallbladder
removal surgery on Saturday.
So, by Sunday, our registration
was actually dead.
But I came --
I brought our rings
and a little dress,
and I said, "Is there a chaplain
in the house?"
I was actually
talking to my mom,
and my little dress
was on the chair,
and I was in Tracy´s T-shirt
and some grippy socks.
And she just walked in.
She´s like, "Hello, I´m Robin.
I´m gonna do a wedding."
And I was like, "I got to go.
I´m getting married."
[ Laughter ]
And so, she just made up
this Lutheran ceremony.
It was just the three of us.
And my husband was so high.
-Oh, that´s great.
-He was so high.
-Was he -- Could he get up?
-No, no, no.
-No. So he was in bed?
-Oh, in bed.
And his, like --
His gown was slightly
off the shoulder, you know?
He was just, like, so high.
-He probably --
My dream was always
an off-the-shoulder gown.
[ Laughter ]
My wife wouldn´t
let me do it, so...
-She was able --
Her gown probably fit
really easily.
-Yeah, she did really good.
She cleared out everything.
She was ready to go.
-Good for her.
That´s the way to do it.
-That´s the way to do it.
Like, you don´t need
to go on a diet.
Just get a little food poisoning
right at the end.
-Something. Absolutely.
-Well, and I think you have
an anniversary coming up?
-Yeah, end of the month.
I always get the day mixed up,
because we actually cheated
by backdating it one day,
because it was expired.
So I think it´s the 30th.
-30th, right.
-State of Illinois,
it´s the 30th.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-I´ll make sure to send flowers
on that day.
-Happy anniversary to you, too.
-Thank you very much.
September 1st.
-Thank you.
-Carrie Coon, everybody!